un arrêt un moment de recueillement le
temps pour Justin Trudeau de se souvenir
d'un sombre chapitre de l'histoire du
Cambodge
on évalue que le génocide mené par
l’hick mer Rouge a fait 2 millions de
morts dans les années 70 dans cette
ancienne prison humilié de personnes ont
été affamées torturés tués nous
inventions
de se souvenir
pour ne jamais voir répéter nulle part
ailleurs
de voir de mémoire pour un premier
ministre confronté au grand défi du
monde actuel au très attendu sommet du
G20 Justin Trudeau et ses alliés devront
trouver comment se dresser devant de
grands régimes autoritaires comme la
Chine et la Russie le Premier ministre
mis sur la fermeté pour dénoncer la
guerre en Ukraine c'est une guerre qui
fait des ravages horribles et qui a des
répercussions partout dans le monde
Poutine a créé une crise énergétique de
l'insécurité alimentaire le Canada
annoncera un nouveau plan d'aide à
l'Ukraine pendant le G20 et promet de
tout faire pour isoler la Russie au
sommet Justin Trudeau à l'intention
d'ignorer le ministre des Affaires
étrangères russes en général où j'ai pas
particulièrement intérêt à parler
directement à lavera mais concernant la
Chine il reste plus vague va-t-il
aborder avec sijin ping la gérance
chinoise dans les élections canadiennes
de 2019 ils ne s'engage pas formellement
à parler au leader chinois comme
toujours je vais souligner la question à
endroits humains des principes de
défense de nos institutions avec tous
les leaders avec qui j'ai des
conversations mais lundi les yeux du
monde seront tournés vers les présidents
chinois et américains pour leur premier
tête-à-tête depuis que Joe byden est à
la Maison Blanche
de tension autour de l'autonomie de
Taïwan les deux rivaux se mesure et
s'évaluent Joe Biden cherche à
identifier les lignes à ne pas franchir
entre les deux pays
le groupe des vins apparaît plus divisé
que jamais deux blocs s'affrontent d'un
côté les pays occidentaux bien décidés à
isoler Moscou et de l'autre ceux qui ont
refusé de condamner l'invasion russe en
Ukraine un tel clivage laisse peu de
place au compromis et réduit les espoirs
d'en arriver à des avancées concrètes à
l'issue du G20 ici Louis Blouin
Radio-Canada